[Music]
this morning we take you to one of the
last remnants of what new york was like
before new york city ever existed a
small old-growth forest found inside the
new york botanical garden it survived
everything from war to farming to real
estate development but now it faces a
new threat michael george takes us
inside
long before the crowds of times square
and the lights of broadway
this is what new york city looked like
and this is what it sounded like
a forest that has not been cut down
has been untouched by humankind
the thane family forest 50 acres of old
growth natural woods within the new york
botanical garden in the bronx
when the first leaves come out when do
the buds come out few people know the
magic of this place better than joanne
strauss a bronx native who's been coming
here since she was a young girl what
makes this place special
well just look around
you can't believe you're in the middle
of new york city you can't believe
you're in the bronx it's so peaceful
it's quiet
joanne still walks these same trails
today as a tour guide and a volunteer
studying the forest's ecosystem
i started volunteering here 20 years ago
i can't believe it it seems like
yesterday and i started in the master
composter program and so that's how i
got involved i
said i have to be here more often do you
feel that this kind of volunteer work is
more important now than ever yes
absolutely we want to educate people we
want to introduce people to the the
wonders of nature and how important it
is for us to preserve this natural place
and other natural places that we have
the forest is nestled between the bronx
river parkway and a metro north station
just over three miles from yankee
stadium but it's easy to miss even for
locals
do most new yorkers even know this
exists i don't think so because many
times people come here and they say i
grew up in new york all my life i had no
clue
the bronx river makes this place a
perfect refuge for native species like
owls foxes and migratory birds they're
trees that have been standing here since
the american revolution
but the history of this forest actually
predates america itself we should
acknowledge that we are on ancestral
land of the lenape people and we're
going up this ridge here elliott nagle
of the new york botanical garden is the
forest's director
so there is evidence to show that the
lenape used this land for hunting but we
don't besides that we don't know exactly
how they would have used this forest
specifically
when colonists arrived they quickly
found they couldn't use this land for
farming when you look through the site
it's very hilly and rocky that's one of
the reasons why up in through to the
development of the new york botanical
garden that the forest was preserved so
the forest remained undeveloped
natural
in 1895 the city formally set aside this
space entrusting its protection to the
botanical garden
is this forest the way it was hundreds
and hundreds of years ago absolutely not
and so that's one of the amazing things
to see is that our natural ecosystems
are constantly changing that interaction
with the city is causing all different
types of changes
time and time again invasive species
have threatened the ecosystem here it's
taken generations of work to protect the
native plants and animals and now
there's a new threat to the survival of
this place
severe weather events are already having
an impact
all these downed trees are from ida
absolutely yeah that's just some of the
impacts of our severe storms
when the remnants of hurricane ida
battered new york last september the
forest wasn't spared so when you talk
about threats to the forest like
invasive species like weather events
does climate change make those things
worse as you increase those weather
events and the severity of them then we
do increase the amount of disturbance in
the forest increasing canopy gaps but
also invasive species coming into those
areas and thriving and by monitoring a
forest like this we can monitor those
impacts we can identify management
practices to effectively treat them
before they even have an opportunity to
impact more of our larger rural areas
upstate
the hope is to ensure this place
continues to give us a living breathing
window into new york's past for
centuries to come
what's at stake if we lose this forest i
think it would be devastating look
around
inhale deeply you're just transported to
a different world here there's nothing
like being close to nature there's kind
of a quiet beauty to it that i think
everyone has the opportunity to come
here and explore and discover the site
for themselves and i hope they do
for cbs saturday morning michael george
the bronx